c'est une première au québec les
étudiants ont commencé à voter par
anticipation aujourd'hui directement au
cégep ou à l'université
et d'ailleurs ils ont été un peu plus de
7000 à le faire des chiffres en début
d'après midi ça pourrait être plus élevé
en fait on veut encourager évidemment
par cette mesure les jeunes électeurs à
se rendre aux urnes ce soit par
anticipation ou le 7 avril aux portes à
jean-sébastien cloutier
voilà un des premiers votes déposés pour
cette élection québécoise il n'y avait
peut-être pas foule ce vendredi matin à
l'uqam mais les étudiants qui ont
profité de leur nouveau service de vote
par anticipation était bien heureux
j'aime venir encore donc directement je
suis venu voter c'est quelque chose qui
est vraiment plus pratique pas ce que tu
fais ça vite vite moi j'adore ce dès que
j'ai vu ça sur le site internet je me
suis j'ai appelé mon ami nexity bon on
va voter vendredi le let's go
à l'heure du dîner dans le petit bureau
de scrutin du cégep maisonneuve
plusieurs jeunes voté aussi avec l'
avantage là comme ailleurs de pouvoir
donner leur appui au candidat de leur
choix dans la circonscription de leur
domicile alejandro gouttière est allé
voter pour la première fois c'est
réjouissant je trouve on peut
s'impliquer directement la société et le
fait que ce soit à l'école passe encore
mieux ça encourage fortement les
étudiants les voter c'est justement ce
que souhaite le directeur général des
élections pense que son intérieur
75% comme on a lu à la dernière élection
pour l'ensemble de la population des
électeurs je prends ce serait une belle
réussite l'objectif est ambitieux parce
qu'en 2008 seulement 36 % des 18-24 ans
étaient allés voter en 2012 après le
printemps étudiants le taux avait grimpé
à 62%
auriez vous voté sinon c'est parce que
non sincèrement je pense canon avec
laura de travail pilot road du cégep
mais se rendent souvent c'est difficile
puis perdre des heures de travail puis
c'est ça c'est compliqué de vote de plus
grâce à ses nouveaux bureaux de vote
mais combien y en aura-t-il un texte une
bonne mesure mais en même temps les
jeunes qui fréquentent les collèges et
universités sont des jeunes qui ont
tendance à voter davantage que les
autres jeunes donc l'impact va être
assez faible et d'autant plus que les
enjeux que l'on observe dans la campagne
électorale actuelle soit l'économie la
santé sont pas des enjeux qui touchent
particulièrement les jeunes françois
gélineau ne crois donc pas que cette
nouvelle mesure favorisera un parti
plutôt qu'un autre l'opinion des jeunes
étant de toute façon divisée dans les
sondages trois autres journées de vote
sont prévues dans les écoles la semaine
prochaine ici jean sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal